der mysteriöse entführungsfall der
kleinen amy aus halle am morgen des 6
dezembers wurde das mädchen von zwei
joggern aus der saale gezogen
jetzt steht fest die sechsjährige wurde
opfer eines verbrechens sie wurde von
einem mann entführt
anhand von zwei phantombildern die
aufgrund von unterschiedlichen
zeugenaussagen erstellt wurden und einer
beschreibung sucht die polizei halle
saale nun nach dem mutmaßlichen täter
er soll zwischen 20 und 40 jahre alt
sein mittelgroß und eine helle hautfarbe
haben
er trägt rotes möglicherweise gefärbtes
deckhaar mit kurz rasierten seiten
zudem soll er auffällige ex beine haben
zur tatzeit war er mit einer dunklen
jacke mit einer wein rot grauen kapuze
bekleidet er trug eine überlange am
boden schleifen de dunkle hose einen
gelb blauen schal und einen dunklen
rucksack die kripo stellt sich nun die
frage was geschah mit der sechsjährigen
emi aus halle
bild rekonstruiert den zwei kilometer
langen fußweg des mädchens von ihrem
wohnort zum späteren fundort an der
saale in dem haus hinter mir unbehagen
der innenstadt von halle an der saale
verschwand am sonntagmorgen die
sechsjährige emi nachdem das mädchen
gerettet und ins krankenhaus gebracht
wurde begann bei der polizei eine
umfangreiche ermittlungen hier in der
wohnung des opfers bei ihren
ermittlungen kamen die kriminalisten der
ermittlungsgruppe elsa schnell darauf
dass der täter mit dem kind durch die
stadt gelaufen sein muss
also hat man angefangen sich sämtliche
überwachungsbilder von kameras die auf
dem weg lagen anzusehen dieser platz zum
beispiel ist mit kameras der polizei
ausgestattet hier ist der täter mit dem
kind mit dem opfer auf dem arm vorbei
man sieht so wissen die ermittler dass
das kind nur mit einem schlafanzug und
mit socken bekleidet war
durch diese straße kommt man direkt auf
den halleschen marktplatz
dort ist der täter auch von kameras
gefilmt wurden
deshalb ist der weg den er zurückgelegt
hat sehr gut dokumentiert die saale
hatte am sonntagmorgen
temperaturen kurz über dem gefrierpunkt
man geht davon aus dass das mädchen nur
ganz wenige augenblicke werden überhaupt
minuten im wasser war das große glück
dass sie gehört wurde und sich bemerkbar
machen konnte experten sagen länger als
zehn minuten hätte sie das auf keinen
fall überlebt die ermittlungsgruppe elsa
sucht nun dringend nach zeugen die bei
der aufklärung des falls helfen können
alle hinweise nimmt die polizeidirektion
halle saale entgegen unter der
telefonnummer 0345 224 1 291 wir sind
bild und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren